[Music]
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today the
national retail Federation believes
Americans will continue spending this
holiday season despite inflation and uh
they have proven it Halloween alone is
expected to reel in
12.2
billion with the average participant
spending
$18.24 this marks the a $2 billion jump
compared to last year for Halloween
frightening two billion that is
frightening Bo Americans are expected to
spend 4.1 billion on costumes alone wow
pet costumes have become a recent Trend
that real ters are capitalizing on pet
owners are expected to spend around 700
million on dressing up their
pets
um I'm a
G I just I can't get mine it's it's not
good it's it's a
catastrophe what do you think about
that guys in the booth like that one
catastrophe okay that's why you get the
big bucks well here's the thing it says
there are countries with lower gdps than
12.2 billion so we spend more on
Halloween than some countries even spin
to just be there yeah listen I'm not
buying my Peta costume if you want to
buy your petac costume that's okay but
let me tell you what you shouldn't be
doing okay you should not be buying your
pet or yourself a
costume if you're whining about student
loan forgiveness uhoh you should not be
buying your pet or
yourself a costume if you've not been
generous and given more than that amount
away to someone a human being that's in
need like a hungry child Wow versus your
shihu with a tutu
I'm glad you said Shih
Tzu I'm just saying unbelievable yeah I
it's okay if you want to dress your pet
up but if your generosity factor is
lower than your personal costume
combined with your pet costume you have
issues if you're broke and your kid is
taking out a student loan because you
don't have any money and they're going
to
college but your labador retriever
or Worse your golden
doodle
is all doodled up yeah
then I mean again it it's not the issue
is not actually the actual spending the
issue is what you're not doing while
you're spending this yeah that would
drive that's that's you know in a
country where all we hear about is oh
all this drama about how house prices
are so high you Boomers don't understand
you were able to buy a house for
$13 and you don't understand you're
you're right we don't understand while
you're dressing up your golden doodle
for Halloween we don't understand you're
right we we think you're nuts that's
true look where I come from if you had a
roll of foil and the old like a couple
of old toilet paper rolls you can make a
costume well I'm hey I like a party and
you know I'm pretty much into candy and
free candy coming from other people like
the prog the program is a good program I
like the program but if inflation is
your problem if you're worried about
living payche to paycheck you can't sit
around and whine about wealth
inequality when we spent $4.1 billion do
on costumes but Americans are the poor
is getting poorer and the rich is
getting richer and oh my God and you
just can't have these both these things
coming out of your mouth it makes you
look stupid yeah it makes you look as
stupid as you are when you do that stuff
stuff so it's okay celebrate Halloween
celebrate Christmas celebrate your pets
spend money on your pets I don't care
but then don't tell me that there's
hungry children in your neighborhood or
within 25 miles of where you're sitting
right now and you haven't done something
about feeding them that's very good
that's just wrong I mean we live in the
wealthiest Nation the world has ever
known in terms of total dollars and and
we prove it with this these kinds of
numbers so I I really am not the Grinch
I'm not against Christmas and I guess
the Grinch was probably for Halloween I
don't know how I don't know I don't know
his exact stance on Halloween I haven't
checked the Grinch on Halloween but he
probably Pro Halloween yeah he's
probably Pro Halloween but um you know
either way I'm not I'm not against all
this I know I'm not against fun I like
fun Fun's a good thing but you shouldn't
do it at the expense of the things that
should be a priority and you can't do it
while you're whining and complaining
about about the world coming to an end
because it's so unfair out there while
I'm running around chasing my own stupid
tail and you certainly shouldn't be
putting it on credit cards cuz I know
some of y'all went over to Home Depot
and those big giant skeletons that I see
in everybody's yard and those tombstones
cool they're giant they're amazing but
they're like 500 bucks a pop yeah my my
grandkids saw that the other day Papa
Dave you got to get one of those I
didn't but they told me I got to get one
Papa Dave you didn't get one Papa Dave
didn't get one so expensive it's just
I'm it's not that I you know I'm not
against large skeletons I'm perfectly
good if you're a large skeleton you're
on my team I'm just saying I'm I'm I'm
for you I'm for the large skeleton the
the large skeleton Union and Dave we're
in good shape I'm I support the union
but the uh oh my gosh y'all seriously
12.2 B
billion billion it's a lot that's a
thousand million a billion it's Rec
spending million oh it is record
spending in one of the worst economy
I mean the economy this time last year
was Boom Town compared to right now well
you know what that's an interesting
thing Dave because you ever go out to
dinner and it's like a Tuesday night and
it's not you can't get in a restaurant
it's totally full can't get in a
restaurant right now I'm like is this a
myth because when I go to Home Depot
people are buying the skeletons and when
I go to dinner it's packed full in there
it's the uh it's the Walmart measure of
the economy if the economy is horrible
but the Walmart parking lot is full
something's wrong with your measure o
you know so um cuz you know Walmart
customers are not usually known as the
same customer as Nordstrom that's so if
the Walmart people are out there
spending uh that tells you the economy
is probably not as bad as somebody
saying it is so I I I think the economy
is very slow right now I think it's very
sluggish we got these ridiculous High
interest rates on uh houses right now um
so let's uh dress up like a kid and have
a party yeah
I guess that's the plan it's kind of
like during uh the fouchy pandemic when
the uh booze sales oh yeah they went
Wine and Booze sales went through the
roof the liquor stores racked up I mean
very few people made more during the
fouchy pandemic uh than the liquor
stores except the plexiglass people well
it really goes to show the plexiglass
people cashed in now people will figure
out a way to cope with whatever it is
obviously in Co people did wine and
beers and things like that that's what
it is we traded one mask for another oh
whoa okay that's what it is that's
profound Dave who knew so we got used to
covering our faces that's what it is
that's profound I like so you know so
increase of $2 billion in Halloween
spending this year interesting rent
interesting discussion just you know the
thing is all we want you to do on all of
these things is
think I know it's a strain but put down
your phone and
think think think because if you in one
breath are saying how horrible the world
is and in another breath are spending
$800 for a giant skeleton in your front
yard something's off in your little deal
right there baby you you need to think
you need to think this through and so
taking care of your kids taking care of
your adult
responsibilities and having a party can
all happen at the same time there is not
a problem with that got no issue with
that at all but you can't just you can't
have it both ways not not and look
intelligent I mean you look you look
foolish when you try to do it both ways
it just it doesn't play through for you
so consumers will be shopping early for
festive decor and other related items
retailers are prepared with the
inventory to help customers and their
families take part in this popular and
fun devil worship I mean tradition you
sounded like my
parents it couldn't this